[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jacqueline gourault bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nominés de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales et on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur le
ministre
jacqueline go on va bien sûr parler du
projet de loi décentralisation qui était
en examen actuellement au sénat mais
d'abord la crise sanitaire de nouvelles
mesures de lutte contre le coc vides ont
donc été présenté lundi soir par le chef
de l'état on en connaît les détails on
connaît la bon projet de loi qui sera
présenté en conseil des ministres la
semaine prochaine
examinée au parlement dans la foulée
l'une des principales mesures c'est la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants et pour les pompiers
est ce que vous regrettez que le
gouvernement ne soit pas allée plus loin
sur ce sujet avec la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous comme le demandent
et françois bayrou notamment je crois
d'abord c'est une étape importante déjà
de demander à tous les soignants de se
faire vacciner et je crois que le
président de la réplique de la
république pardon à comment dire bien
expliqué que c'était une étape et que le
but c'est de vacciner un maximum de
français
on sait aujourd'hui c'est quand même
bien de rappeler que 42% même un peu
plus près ce que 43% des français ont
reçu les deux doses nécessaires et qu'il
y a à peu près 50 3% qui ont reçu une
dose
naturellement tout va être fait pour que
la vaccination soit la plus efficace
possible
vous savez d'abord qu'il y a un stock de
vaccins très important je crois que
c'est bien de le dire
deuxièmement vous savez que les français
ont entendu le message du président de
la république dans la mesure où il y a
jamais eu autant d'inscriptions par le
système d'octo libre hier on disait plus
enfin un million sept de personnes
s'étaient inscrites ce qui est énorme
bien évidemment ces dix sept fois plus
que que d'habitude
il ya ce que vous nous dites madame amis
c'est que c'est que ça va ça va suffire
comme ça parce que la question dorian
était plutôt celle de savoir si les
professions pour laquelle la vaccination
est obligatoire
ça suffira ou est-ce qu'il faudra aller
plus loin est ce qu'il faut par exemple
réfléchir à la vaccination des
enseignants pour la rentrée à celle des
forces de l'ordre dont beaucoup de gens
se disent que c'est quand même un peu
étrange qu'ils soient pas vacciner alors
qu'ils vont contrôler ceux qui ne sont
pas ne pas vacciner
c'est bizarre non on commence par
obliger ceux qui sont auprès des plus
fragiles c'est à dire les personnes
âgées
c'est à dire les malades dans les
hôpitaux etc
je crois que c'est tout à fait logique
et c'est un signe qui montre qu'il faut
que tous les français soient vaccinés et
bien évidemment je voulais vous dire
qu'il y à aussi tout cas sont des
français soient vaccinés mais pas de
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français étaient peut-être que ça
viendra je ne dis pas que ça ne viendra
pas mais en tout cas le président de la
république a fait ça par étapes
c'est un choix je public à laisser
n'importe où et le oui absolument et je
dirais par ailleurs qu'il ya toute une
politique d'aller vers qui se met en
place devant oriane je vais dire que ça
se fait déjà dans certains territoires
comme en corse où on va dans les
villages avec
des bus pour vacciner notamment les bus
france service pour vacciner les
habitants des villages
il faut multiplier la les verts il va y
avoir la vaccination aussi à la rentrée
pour les jeunes dans les écoles
donc il y a beaucoup d'actes qui sont
faits pour que les français soient
vaccinés c'est le bonheur n'arrive pas à
la vaccination obligatoire mais ça sera
le cas c'est ça mais et on verra comment
mais déjà c'est très encourageant
l'inscription et puis je voudrais
préciser aussi qu'il y à une autre
mesure qui est celle de mettre en
isolement alors j'allais voir je vais
vous le dire parce qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est étonnant c'est que
le président de la république n'a
absolument pas parlé de cette question
du durcissement des conditions de
l'isolément et puis là on découvre dans
l'avant projet de loi
en effet il va y avoir un isolement en
tout cas demandé aux parlementaires un
isolement obligatoire de 10 jours
contrôlé par les forces de l'ordre alors
d'une part c'est quand même étonnant que
ça débarque que comme ça et puis
deuxièmement est-ce qu'on va aller
jusqu'à des sanctions par exemple alors
que ça avait été écarté en fin d'année
dernière le président de la république a
dit clairement vous rappeler dans son
discours qu'il n'y avait aucune raison
que les français qui ont joué un jeu
très tôt qui se sont vaccinés pâtissent
de cette nouvelle crise due aux variants
à delta et que c'était ce qui ne se
faisait pas vaccinés qui devrait au fond
subir entre guillemets
et quand les mesures de rigueur plus
importante et a parlé de sévices et bien
sûr ce que pensaient les vacciner c'est
une manière aussi de dire que ceux qui
sont pas vaccinés et qu'on met à l'
isolement il faut faire en sorte qu'ils
ne puissent pas quand elles brisent les
sanctions c'est l'agression on verra ce
que le texte
comment le texte sur votre opinion l'a
déjà de d'exiger de les mettre à
l'isolément pendant dix jours
c'est déjà en soi une mesure importante
d'accord donc mais donc on ne saura pas
si vous êtes pour les sanctions mais il
ya quand même une autre question qui se
pose parce que on a vu combien une valse
hésitation et nous dans l'est dans les
territoires on interroge les gens alors
ils nous disent que un directeur de
salle de spectacle et nous confier
depuis un an il a appris à attendre
parce que entre les annonces et la
réalité il ya souvent des différences et
le fait est qu'on peut pas tellement lui
donner tort parce qu'entre les annonces
du président de la république et le
lendemain finalement la souplesse qui a
été apporté à la fois pour la
vaccination des 12-17 ans ou bien pour
la vague de la vaccination le pass and i
ter pardon des personnels de cafés et
restaurants il ya de la souplesse qui a
été apportée est ce que vraiment à
chaque fois on a l'impression d'un vrai
coup de un vrai coup de massue puis
après on revient en arrière parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que c'est bas applicable dans
la réalité ça fait pas très sérieux
toujours non c'est pas ça c'est que le
principe est annoncé par le président de
la république et ensuite le premier
ministre et le ministre des solidarités
et de la santé prévoit la mise en
application dans le détail et on regarde
comment les choses peuvent s'appliquer
c'est simplement ça il ya le principe et
la mise en application
un dernier mot là dessus
j'avais qu'une groupe qu'on a vu hier
des mobilisations dans plusieurs villes
de france contre ces mesures sanitaires
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
manifestants est ce que vous craignez
d'être en train de créer une nouvelle
fracture
d'abord je vous dire je trouve ça assez
scandaleux c'est maintenant ce que j'ai
vu quelques images de gens qui
manifestaient mais qui aussi commencé à
être violents etc etc
je pense qu'il est allé de dictature et
ça va trop loin enfin faut être sérieux
il ya une crise extrêmement importante
extrêmement grave et à ce variant delta
on sait qui est book qui se répand
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'ils aient
beaucoup plus grave
enfin comment dire ce que fait le
gouvernement et le président de la
république s'est protégé les français
c'est éviter que la crise ne se soit
trop grave
et vous avez vu que d'autres pays ont
près ont pris désir soit des nouvelles
mesures
vous avez vu que le couvre-feu revient
en espagne au portugal etc
nous nous avons choisi de ne pas
remettre de couvre-feu comme vous l'avez
vu mais le responsabiliser les fonds c
est de vacciner
je vais dire ya alors un mot d'ordre
c'est vaccinez vous vacciner le pour
vous c'est la grande halle de ces
manifestations c'est ce qu'on aime moi
je trouve ça assez scandaleux et
d'ailleurs je regardais hier soir un peu
les réseaux sociaux et je voyais que je
n'étais pas la seule
on va parler de la loi de
décentralisation qui est examinant son
ancien ingénieur exactement à leurs
textes textes lourds texte riche plus
tôt mais particulièrement décevant d'une
remarquable indigence alors ce sont pas
mes mots un bien sûr ce sont les mouz et
employés par l'addition est lourd
et senna bien sûr je me joins à propos
des deux premiers articles du projet de
loi qui sont censés en constituer la clé
de voûte
alors la commission des lois n'a pas
bien lu en fait le texte et écouter
d'abord il ya les mots la majorité ici
n'est pas une majorité qui correspond à
la majorité présidentielle il faut
toujours mettre ses marques si je puis
dire
mais je vais être très clair cette
lecture première lecture au sénat se
passe je dirai tout à fait correctement
et puisque vous parlez des premiers
articles
les premiers articles les principes de
fond que sont la différenciation que
sont le comment dire le transfert
pas des compétences de transfert de
aux collectivités territoriales
réglementaire est très important je veux
dire sur les principes de fonds
il n'y a pas de divergence importante et
d'ailleurs vous savez la loi quand elle
a été déposée
elle avait un certain nombre d'articles
un peu plus de soixante dix il y en a
cent cinquante huit aujourd'hui est sûre
sans cesse ses 158 articles
quand je suis venu en séance publique
après la commission des lois
nous avons décidé de ne pas modifier
sans article c'est qui est quand même
énorme
il y en a à peu près une trentaine où on
va faire évoluer et 28 où on a de vraies
différences
donc je veux dire que ça va parler 28 ce
sera non non pas ça on discute mais eux
aussi les sénateurs ont des positions le
gouvernement défend un certain nombre de
positions mais je veux dire que la
discussion se passe bien nous avons des
arts des rapporteurs dans toutes les
commissions qui sont eux qui connaissent
très bien le test qui ont beaucoup
travaillé qui ont fait des propositions
on a terminé
mardi le volet logement avec dominique
estrosi sassone nous avons eu un travail
mais je ne vous dirai pas en parler on
va en parler tout de suite mais ce lot
sur ces 28 articles quels sont les
points sur lesquels vous ne céderez pas
au sénat c'est pas je ne céderai pas au
sénat parce que faut pas poser les
choses comme ça parce que si on pose les
choses en disant on ne discute pas moi
je suis toujours prêt parce que vous
avez des bons la différence peut-être où
le sénat est allé plus loin que nous ne
le souhaitons c'est tout ce qui concerne
l'intercommunalité jeu françoise gatel
qu'il vient de quitter le micro a fait
voter les compétences à la carte à
l'intérieur de l'intercommunalité a
voulu rajouter de l'intérêt
communautaire dans les communautés
urbaines où les métropoles qui sont
pourtant déjà très intégré ce sont des
pubs je vous parle pas de l'eau et de
l'assainissement parce que c'est
tellement évident à chaque fois
mais voyez jeu là je dirais que le sénat
est allé dans un sens qui ne nous
convient pas parce que cette instance
qui va trop loin alors après on peut
toujours trouver des discussions mais
c'est bien mais je voulais quand même
rené longet ya beaucoup d'autres
domaines où nous avons eu un accord sur
des choses assez fondamentale j'espère
qu'on va y tenir
on a parlé du logement dal a parlé par
exemple des logements sociaux alors les
sénateurs ont adopté le principe d'un
contrat de mixité sociale entre les
communes et le préfet alors ça permet
d'adapter le rythme de rattrapage de
construction de logements sociaux
et si une commune atteint les objectifs
fixés
elle ne sera pas sanctionné même si les
objectifs sont en deçà des 2 ceux de la
loi sru
est-ce que le gouvernement va soutenir
cet amendement a nommé c'était dans le
texte du gouvernement monsieur ses
salles à ces seules la nuance entre ce
que vous me proposez est ce que vous
dites est la réalité c'est que le
contrat de mixité sociale était proposée
par le gouvernement dans le texte
initial
il a été confirmé par le sénat
alors après il y avait des détails de
fonctionnement du contrat de mixité
sociale
mais ce qui est important à retenir
c'est que le sénat a confirmé d'abord le
fait de poursuite de poursuivre la loi
sru puisque vous avez que l'échéance
devait être 2025 donc 1 ils ont accepté
de poursuivre la loi sru
ce qui n'est pas rien en soi mais encore
faut-il qu'elle soit respectée
oui bien sûr mais on a accompagné
c'était la proposition du gouvernement
et en particulier des manuels wargon de
faire des contrats de mixité sociale qui
font qu'on gère au niveau local
là comment dire la mise en place du
logement social
et ça c'est très important parce que on
sait qu'il y a des communes
et c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas très
allantes pour construire du logement
social ça existe et 7,6 et celles ci
seront évidemment sanctionné comme à
l'habitude si elles ne font rien et puis
il ya tous ceux qui voudraient bien
construire du logement social
mais ce logement social parfois est
difficile à construire parce qu'il ya
des contraintes et quoi de mieux que la
proximité et la discussion entre un
préfet est amer et l'intercommunalité
pour adapter et aller vers plus de
logements century parler d un autre
sujet ou alors je suis désolé le texte
est en effet très large et donc pas son
sujet alors un autre sujet de proximité
mais qui a tendance à enflammer les les
discours c'est les éoliennes les
sénateurs veulent donner un droit de
veto aux mères contre l'implantation
d'éoliennes
est-ce que là aussi vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne idée écoutez d'abord le
sujet des éoliennes il a été traité dans
la loi climat et cette loi un climat
avançaient suffit a fait l'objet du cmp
favorable une commission nicobar il a
fait daccord députés sénateurs et donc
les sénateurs et les députés se sont mis
d'accord y compris sur le texte des
éoliennes donc on va pas dans ce texte y
revenir mais sauf que sur les éoliennes
pardon mais dans l'accord le droit de
veto il a été retiré
donc il ya plus de droit de véto à
l'heure actuelle la les sénateurs l'ont
robin la loi de la centralisation est là
aussi vous demander son retrait bien sûr
nous n'allons pas mais nous n'allons pas
le gouvernement pas ne pas accepter ce
droit de veto alors qu' il y a eu une
cmp conclusive mardi mais est ce qu est
ce que vous comprenez en fait ce besoin
de peut-être de reprendre des régions
des territoires de reprendre un peu de
pouvoir sur ces sur ces implantations
on le voit par exemple dans la région de
france le président xavier bertrand en
est à subventionner des associations
pour deux militants contre les
implantations parce que il y en a trop
et ça se fait sans contrôle de la part
d'aidé des pouvoirs locaux
oui alors votons premiers mois je veux
dire tout n'est pas noir et blanc parce
que beaucoup des éoliennes se sont
installés aussi parce que des mères
étaient volontaires pour accepter des
éoliennes
je crois qu'il faut pas non plus samedi
au sens où les maires de france j'habite
une région enfin vous prenez la disent
là vous voyez quand vous partez il vous
traversé toute la beauce et ça va jusque
dans le département de loir et cher la
beauce je peux vous dire qu'il dit à des
endroits où je connais je pourrais vous
citer des merdes qui a été volontaire
parce que il y avait des ressources
nouvelles qui venait là donc
après il ya eu beaucoup d'associations
qui se sont il ya même une association
qui s'appelle tempête en beauce je vais
vous donner je vais qui est contre
l'implantation des éoliennes mais il
faut raison garder et que tout cela
je dirais soit fait dans le dialogue et
y compris avec les maires autre question
et c'est vrai qu'il faut donc on parle
des routes et les sénateurs sont vent
debout contre la possibilité de
transférer la gestion de routes
nationales vers l'est vers les régions
argon que c'est pas vraiment de leurs
compétences là aussi vous allez comment
vous allez négocier ce virage
justement sur cette route je ne suis pas
sûr que les sénateurs soit tout ce vent
debout
d'abord parce que la plupart des régions
son cours et je dirais même au début
elles étaient quelques-unes le vouloir
et maintenant elles sont presque toutes
à le demander ce qui est clair c'est que
c'est une expérimentation alors que nous
avons votée ça a été voté le transfert
des routes nationales vers les
départements qui le souhaitent
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
différenciation et l'expérimentation du
transfert de route nationale est
souhaitée par beaucoup de présidents de
région et je pense que nous trouverons
un accord avec le cdh à un accord donc
un accord est justement jacqueline
gourault le texte qui sera voté mercredi
au sénat est ce qu'après il ira à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
nous assurer que ce texte a inscrit au
calendrier l'assemblée nationale et
qu'alors je les dis publiquement dans
l'assemblée puisque le sénateur de la
marne
a posé la question j'ai dit qu'il n'y
avait pas encore de calendrier fixé à la
rentrée mais pas plus pour la loi 4 dès
que pour d'autres lois deuxièmement j'ai
dit que vu la manière dont se passent
les discussions au sénat qui sont je
dirais globalement constructive
je pense que plus ce sera constructif
plus ça donnera des chances d'être
inscrit
je crois que c'est entre les mains des
sénateurs vous leur dites je dis vrai
que c'est en réalité valeur lorsque
c'est entre les mains du gouvernement
mais je dis que plus il y à un texte qui
respecte déséquilibre plus évident est
clairement ça veut dire quoi que si le
texte dérange les députés de la majorité
présidentielle et qui n'est pas conforme
à leurs attentes ils seraient pas
inscrits au calendrier j'ai pas le temps
de finir mes phrases
c'est d'éclairer on sait pas
l'impression de déranger vous dérange
pas plus un texte je dirais respecte les
grands équilibres de ce que le
gouvernement a voulu faire mais un
gouvernement qui a fait ses textes
après beaucoup de consultations je les
dis et redis j'ai fait plus de deux
mille consultations sur le territoire en
plus des consultations avec les
associations d'élus
évidemment c'est un texte équilibré et
plus il reste équilibré plus il a des
chances d'être inscrit rapidement à
l'assemblée nationale on ne sait pas 45
100 % si on vous suit je vous dis
qu'elles sont je vais pas
voilà on va terminer évidemment j'ai
imaginé bien que personnellement je
pense que ce texte est très important à
la fois pour le gouvernement et pour les
collectivités territoriales et justement
on va parler de deux collectivités
territoriales dont vous occuper plus
précisément d'abord l'alsace puisque
vous êtes là madame alsace du
gouvernement frédéric bierry le
président de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace a annoncé le soir des
régionales qu'il consulterait la
population d'alsace sur la sortie de
l'alsace du grand est ce qu est ce que
vous pensez de cette consultation
là je dis tout simplement que nous avons
travaillé beaucoup avec frédéric bierry
et brigitte klinkert
et les choses ont toujours été très
clair c'était alors edouard philippe qui
était premier ministre
nous avions la place et un cadre qui
était très précis c'était oui nous
accompagnons ce que les alsaciens appelé
le désir d'alsace il y avait eu un
rapport fait par le préfet marc préfet
du grand test et nous avions dit oui
nous vous soutiendrons vous accompagnons
mais pas de sortie du grand est c'était
clair et net
donc la faire c'est fait si je peux dire
la collectivité européenne d'alsace que
j'ai vraiment accompagner avec tous les
alsaciens a été créée elle a été mise en
place au début de cette année
2021 et des élections ont lieu comme
dans tous les départements ce que vous
n'êtes pas favorable à notre consultant
vous n'oubliez pas que la ceeac la
fusion de deux départements le haut-rhin
et le bas-rhin avec quelques compétences
supplémentaires
voilà qui était permise du fait du
caractère frontalier de l'alsace pendant
mais moi je dit jeudi à frédéric bierry
et aux alsaciens regardez un peu comment
ça fonctionne votre collectivité
européenne d'alsace voyons salle ne
crions pas les cartouches de cette
création de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qui s'est bien passé et
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas à la
sortie du grand tessin armes d'un mot
rapidement sur la corse puisque vous
êtes aussi la madame corse du
gouvernement les nationalistes qui sont
sortis ultra majoritaire après les
dernières territoriales j simoneau
présidente du conseil exécutif qui a
désormais la majorité absolue il appelle
l'état à devenir le partenaire de son
projet d'autonomie est ce qu emmanuel
macron peut continuer à rester sourd aux
revendications des nationalistes corses
plus tard je voudrais rappeler et vous
le savez que la collectivité de corse
collectivité unique est une collectivité
à statut particulier et que déjà
ces sommes c'est la collectivité la plus
comment on va dire autonome entre
guillemets
de france donc déjà il y a beaucoup de
de compétences entre les mains
des élus de cette collectivité et bien
évidemment est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
aller plus loin
ce n'est pas au programme pour l'instant
mais je sais que j'ai eu c'est aumônier
que j'ai eu très rapidement au téléphone
souhaiterait lui allez vous faire encore
plus d'autonomie
c'est un sujet dont nous avions déjà
parlé quand il y avait la réforme de la
constitution et que nous avions proposé
d'aller plus loin avec l'inscription de
la corse dans la constitution et c'est
dans le cadre de l'article 72 mais déjà
jl-c sonné simeoni demandé d'aller vers
un statut plus ressemblant à l'article
73 ou 74 et dernière question j'ai une
dernière question qui concerne l'un de
vos collègues eric dupond moretti qui
est convoqué demain comme vous le savez
par la cour de justice de la république
en vue d'une mise en examen probable en
2017 je vais pas vous le rappeler mais
françois bayrou alors de garde des
sceaux a été mise en cause dans la
sphère des assistants européen du modem
avait choisi de quitter le gouvernement
avant même cette mise en examen est ce
que vous pensez que votre collègue eric
dupond-moretti devrait faire de même
d'abord je ne sais pas s'il va être mis
en examen
c'est le premier point et deuxièmement
je les fais je ne ferai aucun
commentaire sur ce sujet d'accord donc
pas de commentaires avaient fait le
choix de quitter le gouvernement je ne
ferai aucun commentaire sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin julien la une de la voix
du nord c'est le passe à lithaire
comment le faire appliquer c'est toute
la question
toute la complexité c'est à lire dans la
voix du nord merci beaucoup et on fasse
aussi le club détaille temps